motorcycle crashes on the rise across
las vegas madison kimbra went to a local
shop today and spoke with experts to
shed light on this serious issue she
joins us live now with more madison
a 63-year-old man died yesterday after
hitting the curb median here on
tropicana and koval he hit that with his
motorcycle and today i spoke to a man
who just survived his own bike crash and
lives to tell his story
once my tire blew i kind of lost control
of the bike kind of threw me off
and then i
when i hit the concrete i guess i lost
consciousness and it slid into the wall
bryant huff is lucky to be alive after
getting into a motorcycle accident last
month he broke his arm and injured his
foot but says that won't stop him from
riding again according to the office of
traffic safety there has been more than
a 50 percent increase in the number of
motorcyclists hit and killed this year
the owners of vegas power sports says
they have received a lot of interest in
their bikes during the pandemic
especially from new customers who have
never ridden before there's been a huge
increase in first-time writers that
scott i can't describe how much has gone
up it's been unprecedented for everybody
and with that comes the importance of
knowing what to expect when you're on
the bike when you're in a motorcycle
you've got to understand that if you hit
something you're going to hit it with
the same force that the motorcycle is
you have absolutely no protection mopeds
bicycles scooters and specialty rides
have also seen an increase in crashes
too so far in 2021 zero fatalities has
reported 10 deaths compared to one last
year in 2020
with bike safety vegas power sports is
offering free motorcycle safety classes
for those that purchase a motorcycle
with them reporting live madison
kimbrough live local now